hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to the
Mario Brothers have not translated well
into other mediums have they videogames
of course were so popular that they had
to try other avenues of marketing this
of course led to a shitty movie come on
a shitty TV show be with you and a
shitty comic-book series
insert audio clip from that here I guess
the reason being the story is so strange
and only really works in the videogame
world for example why does a feather
suddenly turn you into a superhero look
nothing from the movies in this yeah so
maybe Mario was only meant to live in
the video game world and nowhere else
that is except for one other evidence
you all remember Nintendo Power you know
the only magazine kids read more than
Playboy
well they had a series of comics that
told a story in every single issue most
were pretty generic like these Nestor
comics that just promoted the game of
the week but by far the best was the
Super Mario Adventures yeah the one
element that Nintendo could never
breathe life into and any other medium
was suddenly the best comic series the
magazine ever had and probably the only
spin-off in the franchise that actually
worked
but why and how did they work let's take
a little closer look the story is pretty
much the same as any other Mario story
Bowser invades the Mushroom Kingdom
kidnaps Princess Toadstool yeah remember
when she was actually called told
stonestep peach and it's up to the Mario
Brothers to save the day so why is that
worth reading seeing how we've seen this
plot millions of times before well the
first reason being there's actually
character in this version I mean okay
they're not Tennessee Williams poor
trails but let's face it over the years
mario has not had much of a personality
in the games it's me Mario
no he's nice I guess but there's not
much to him outside of that except being
a generic Italian stereotype oh I know I
know a lot of you couldn't see it I just
have a very strong feeling
Bowser's a generic villain stereotype
peach is a generic danzel stereotype the
only one to have any character over the
years ironically as the character
everyone forgets about Luigi and even
that's not much he's just sort of formed
a wimpy scaredy-cat persona I guess with
Luigi's Mansion and for whatever reason
I guess that sort of stuck yeah
close your eyes and hit the air that'll
work great but in the comic they do have
more defined personalities Mario for
example is a surprisingly no-nonsense
kind of leader he can tell a joke every
once in a while but for the most part
he's pretty determined without many
giggles or smiles okay granted both him
and Bowser do perform a rap at the
beginning of the comic but to be fair
this was Japanese if I had to guess this
was probably a karaoke thing and the
Americans turn it into a rap thing which
doesn't make it better but okay you just
get past the end the rest of the comic
is good
Luigi again is sort of a wimpy
scaredy-cat but he does pull his weight
in several scenes even Bowser has a
little bit more to him he's his big thug
who tries to get things done in what he
considers the most practical way even if
it always involves force and violence
but he's not just one note he does have
his very goofy even kind of googly eye
scenes all for what he thinks is the
love of Princess Toadstool and here's a
shocker he actually has a reason for
kidnapping her at this time he decides
it's a little hell spawns the Koopa kids
need a mother to look after them and see
how he has the hots for toast do already
the same way I guess the crust species
attraction works in Star Wars he figures
she'd be a perfect pick so yeah there's
even an element of Bowser trying to be a
good father ish okay he's not good at it
but at least he's making the effort they
also make him a great big egotist having
everything his way and destroying
whoever disagrees with him he'll just
look at how much he wants to show off
with the size of the wedding cake at him
and toadstools wedding the thing is so
big that the climax of the comic
actually takes place in the wedding cake
that's pretty funny and then you got
toadstool yeah I know she just sits back
smiling like an idiot and waits for the
Mario Brothers
again right fuck no the chick saves
herself look at this badass bitch she
literally has a whole part of the story
just about her breaking out and kicking
ass it's a really cool escape and every
other panel she wants God to him awesome
even the Mario Brothers at the very end
are like Jesus lady give us some screen
time but on top of that when Bowser
attacks in the opening she doesn't just
sit back and have the Mario Brothers do
all the work she fucking jumps out the
window
gets a mushroom army and goes after him
herself god damn this lady's on fire in
fact believe it or not there's actually
see where Mario gets captured and guess
who the hell hospital save up fucking
princess tawldstole she switched places
with Luigi and ends up blowing the place
apart okay make your own machine I'm
sorry I know I'm really dwelling on this
but for years we've seen this goddamn
fraud do nothing and smile about it and
in the comic she's probably the best
elevating the entire story
god damn Nintendo has to make a game out
of her doing all this cool shit or just
have her crying as the weapon yeah it's
good driver Nintendo's badass all of
your other favorite characters are in
there too like Yoshi the haunted house
ghosts and of course a ton of Bowser's
henchmen and enemies but the best thing
of all about the comic is it's great
sense of humor and I don't mean like
always in that cute Mario said a cat
phrase that'll be dated in a week no I
mean legitimately funny
for example Yoshi in this world can only
seem to say one word Yoshi
so a con-artist salesman decides to sell
them a book translating what they say
the result is you guessed it every
sentence being replaced with Yoshi
another green moment is when they blow
up Bowser's Castle and their adventures
seem to have come to an end so they
literally show the credit like the comic
is officially over but then Mario
interrupts when they realize they have
no way to get back home and thus the
story continues yeah it turns out you're
only at the halfway point but when
you've read the comic you didn't know
that that could have very well been the
ending
it's a legitimately good fake-out even
in the YouTube versions they play their
own credits
stuff like that is great and really
thinks out of the box and the drawing
style by God is fucking hilarious I'm
not usually fan of those animes with our
heads get really big and they yell and
they have the big sweat beads on the
side it just kind of weird for me but
here the comedy matches the visuals just
right
the expressions aren't just kept to
preserving the Mario characters up
healing image they're actually allowed
to go over the top and get some pretty
crazy and hilarious reactions that gives
them a lot more personality and thus
makes them a lot more memorable and the
little touches are especially great
there's a scene where Bowser turns the
mushroom people into stone so much that
even their screams of terror are turned
into stone as well that's pretty
inventive the cartoony line working
colors are also great they just leap off
the page look at half of this with every
panel you can feel the motion you can
feel the energy
this comic instead of just being a lame
little thing on the side actually turned
into one of the highlights of getting
Nintendo power every month you wanted to
read it to get a good laugh and you want
to know what was gonna happen in the
rest of the story it was funny it was
bright it was creative it was just a fun
adventure now after the series ended
they tried a few other monthly comics
like starfox Zelda
even one for Super Metroid we had a much
more badass looking Samus in my opinion
Phil had good artwork in their own right
and we're ultimately okay they told
stories that were similar to the games
but also added a few new characters and
different situations but none of them
quite kept you hook oddly enough as
those weird Mario adventures they just
seemed to connect with a wild
inventiveness that you didn't often see
come from strategy magazines and maybe
that's why it was so good because it did
so much more than people expected it to
do I'm not gonna act like they were
groundbreaking comics or anything like
that but for something that was clearly
just supposed to be a commercial to sell
more videogames and magazines they
actually managed to hook us in with
great artwork hilarious visuals likable
characters and an imagined
didn't take on something we all know and
love it was probably the only time the
Mario franchise was represented well
outside of the games hell even the games
didn't always hit bull's eyes but the
comic did it was clear was having fun
with its world so we were also having
fun with its world it took something
that quite frankly could have just been
phoned in or given little attention and
turned it into something really
enjoyable and really great it was clear
they understood the material it was
based off of and wanted to give us the
same laughs and thrills that the
videogame gave us if you want to check
them out go ahead and look for the Super
Mario adventures graphic novel which is
a collection of all the comics that were
placed in Nintendo Power hell it's got
to be easier than finding every single
than Tendo power they were placed in I'm
not sure if it's easy to find but trust
me if you can it's worth it
with the time and effort it no doubt
took to bring these comics to life it's
nice to know there's still a
professional creative team outside of
the videogame industry that not only got
why we like these video games so much
but also loved and respected it as much
as we do
Island a Schnauzer credit guy remember
so you don't have to